[Music]
river and i finally caught something
it's a fish right makuu no not fish but
stone the only storm there damn i
thought i had one then yeah come on baby
[Music]
the river is clearly not in a given mood
maybe today is not my lucky day yeah
listen what i'd love to do yeah if you
don't mind is taste one yeah and we have
a special way to cook this white fish
that's hard yeah a lot harder than you
think yeah exactly it's quite unique to
be given a chance to fish with this
family because only a few families have
the right to fish along these banks so
a unique experience i just hate going
home empty-handed
makuu has asked his friend kimo to teach
me the traditional way to cook white
fish we're tasting here this bean
finland
it obviously involves a very warm wooden
hut
hello hello how are you
oh give me give me a nice seed gordon
wow this is beautiful yeah oh my god so
traditionally they're all cooked on
sticks like that yeah this inspirational
way a couple hundred years the fish are
rested for 24 hours before they're
cooked and then put on this open fire to
roast
he's turning around every what every
three or four minutes what's your
colored yeah
that's amazing and what are you what are
you seasoning with what's the what's the
seasoning just natural nothing before
nothing until wow hello
wow
what is that very strong salt water and
that's the only way to prepare it and
after after it's ready
so he cools them down in the salted
water yeah the salt water prevents them
from cooking any further and flavors of
the fish
what an amazing technique they look
incredible the smell yeah is amazing
chemo how do you know they're cooked
yes thermometer on his finger right he's
got the you've made the skin almost like
bacon it's crispy yeah not too hard no
but not too soft no but beautiful color
maybe it's the chef in me but i can't
stand by and watch kimo do all the work
without offering a hand kimo do you want
them turned
yeah uh which ones
this turn that one on this
man
into the water okay in
and next one
you gotta move fast because all of a
sudden this one you start off with
nothing and then they're all going this
one
check
hey
yeah
fast fast
this one
now
last two
kimmer two to go
yeah one each because you've done no
you've done the work you just stood
there yeah yes
but i have the fish around too yeah
really
seriously
last one look at that
great
[Music]
come on huh
please know we eat now yes thank you
god look how white that is
huh yeah there's snowball
milton my still oh my goodness me
it doesn't need salt chemo it is really
delicious honestly that's the only
village you can get in the world really
yeah i've eaten a lot of fish in my life
sometimes with chips but that on its own
is delicious um
it's given me a lot of inspiration for
the final cook at the end of the week
and i'd love
for both of you to join us at the final
cookbook okay now would you do me a
favor and go out and get some fish for
the cook at the end of the week that's i
i do immediately after this will you
catch any this time yeah for sure uh
delicious
thank you great job what an amazing fish
delicious it's definitely giving me
inspiration now for the final cook don't
get too clever with this whitefish
first of all we have to follow that
technique and cook it over wood
otherwise
if you start filleting it cooking it
skin side down non-stick pan you're
going to get absolutely slaughtered so
um keep it simple but a nice little a
nice little find the white fish
[Music]
want to see more from my uncharted
adventures please click here to watch
more clips